is it tough this moment to reflect on
what this bubble meant what this journey
meant to you guys where this franchise
was
a year and a half ago was it
um and then
first congratulations to the laker
organization
it was it was great to share this stage
with them and congratulations on the
championship
you know they earned it um
they earned it uh in this series um
definitely wanna i can't we can't thank
the nba enough
uh for this whole experience this has
just been extraordinary
um this bubble this campus uh
the safety protocols um and
and just the whole organization
of everything to be able to be a part of
uh something historic like this to
continue our season
uh we felt or we feel so
um honored and grateful that that we
were able to
to be a part of this and and it took a
big time collaboration between the
league
their vision uh the players association
the leadership of the players
association and the organizations
organizations to make this happen um
it's just really been incredible to to
be a part of this
and you know obviously i want to thank
everybody
in my heat organization
this has been such an unprecedented year
it's taken
everybody
[Music]
to be able to just go all in and
and support uh
the small traveling party that came here
to the bubble
but like rob and a bunch of people
working behind the scenes
uh that nobody gets to see we thank you
uh
and then obviously uh the staff and the
and the players
um actually in this uh
environment we didn't get the final
result
that we wanted but even what i mentioned
to the guys
these are going to be lifetime memories
that we have together this locker room
regardless of whatever happens in the
future we're going to remember this year
this season this experience
and that lack of home locker room
brotherhood for the rest of our lives
um you know you're in this business to
be able to be around people
like this and i can go on and on but
the guys that you know competed and
played
in the series we had several guys that
were not even close to
being 100 and probably shouldn't have
been playing but that's how this
this group uh was they wanted to do it
for each other
and i just i'm really bummed you know
that we couldn't find a way to
to get over the hump and and uh and
finish the season with a win but
that's taking nothing away from the
lakers they played great particularly
tonight